when Yahoo bought you right they gave
you $2.5 billion no they gave us $5.7
billion in stock right and then so I got
33% of it or whatever right and then um
when Yahoo went to about 2 and a half
billion you sold everything when when it
went up I did a a hedge right they
called it one of the top 10 trades all
time on Wall Street what did you do so I
got all the stock from Yahoo and
everybody else thought the internet
bubble was going to keep on going
forever right I'm like there's no way so
I sold calls bought so I protected my
stock and so it went up in value some
more and went up to where my hedge was
and then cashed me out I see and then
the whole market cratered and I was
protected when you cashed out Yahoo went
up a little bit more and people said to
you oh aren't you sorry why didn't you
hold out and you said I've got I've got
two and a half billion how much do you
need right that's exactly and you didn't
get greedy I mean you could have kept
saying I'll stay in another day I'll
stay in another week and if you had
waited just a couple of weeks yeah
probably about six weeks I would have
been